justice toujours à propos du projet de
loi relatifs à la présomption
d'innocence députés et sénateurs se sont
mis d'accord hier soir pour instaurer
l'enregistrement audiovisuel des
interrogatoires des mineurs en garde à
vue ce serait une nouveauté importante
une décision qui pourrait illustrer par
exemple le supplément d'information
requis dans la sphère de patrick dils
en effet hier l'avocat général de la
cour de cassation demandé un complément
d'enquêté dans cette affaire où le
condamné à perpétuité
demande la révision de son procès il est
accusé du meurtre de deux enfants et lui
même étaient âgés de 16 ans au moment
des faits explications clément
weill-raynal luc hedrich rien n'a bougé
dans la chambre de patrick depuis le
jour de son arrestation
lorsque la police est venue l'arrêter
patrick était encore presque un enfant
à 16 ans il collectionnait les soldats
en carton et lisait les bibliothèques
verte ou rose après 48 heures de garde à
vue patrick avait avoué le meurtre de
deux petits garçons âgés de 8 ans cyril
et alexandre dont les corps avaient été
retrouvés non loin de son domicile
le long d'une voie ferrée aujourd'hui
depuis sa prison patrick dils clame son
innocence
joint par téléphone il raconte dans
quelles conditions les aveux consignés
par écrit sur un procès verbal lui
aurait été suggéré scénario on m'a
appris ce scénario que j'avais pu à le
redire après ce qu'il faisait que je
venais à ce moment là l'auteur en fait
ces détails
c'est pas des choses et tu sais des
choses qui m'ont été rapportés tout
simplement parce que je dirais
les personnes qui se sont chargés de
faire mes interrogatoires à l'époque qui
se sont relayés et puis qui ont mis du
coeur à l'ouvragé pour obtenir ce qu'ils
désiraient obtenir non pas obtenir les
aveux du coupable
mais obtenir les aveux d'un coupable ces
gens là venez tous les éléments en main
du dossier
il y avait quelque chose à faire c'est
me laisse suggérer des français publié
l'âge que j'avais à l'époque sur la
qu'une chose c'est qu'on foute la terre
hier devant la cour de cassation
l'avocat général a reconnu que des
éléments nouveaux apparus dans le
dossier de patrick bis justifiait un
complément d'enquêté qui pourrait
conduire à une révision du procès reste
bien sûr les aveux du jeune garçon qui
était mineur à l'époque il aurait été
intéressant a souligné l'avocat général
de disposer des enregistrements de la
garde à vue afin de déterminer dans
quelles conditions les aveux de patrick
dils ont été obtenues